[Música]
hola bienvenidos a la revista digital
donde abordamos los temas más
importantes del ciberespacio y las redes
sociales y los medios de comunicación de
américa latina y el mundo
ante la situación de kobe 19 ahora
trabajamos desde casa con motivo del mes
del orgullo lgtb take un sin número de
marcas han incluido los colores del arco
iris en sus logotipos en redes sociales
y aunque esto ha gozado de gran
aceptación también se ha abierto el
debate sobre si en realidad estas
empresas apoyan a la comunidad o si por
el contrario se están aprovechando de la
situación para comercializar sus
productos empezamos
desde inicios de junio usuarios en redes
sociales inundaron las plataformas con
los colores del arco iris y mensajes en
alusión al mes del orgullo lgtb take a
estas acciones que buscan crear
conciencia sobre las luchas que ha
librado la comunidad y sobre todo los
problemas que aún faltan por resolver se
han sumado desde las más pequeñas a las
más grandes empresas en todo el mundo y
mientras unas sólo han adaptado sus
logos con los colores de la bandera del
gti q otras han lanzado al mercado una
variedad de productos alusivos al tema
aunque esto ha sido bien recibido por
unos como un avance en el reconocimiento
de la diversidad sexual también han
llovido las críticas desde la capital
puertorriqueña pedro julio serrano
activista de la comunidad lgtb rescata
el lado positivo de que hoy las marcas
se involucren de esta manera con el
movimiento pero señala que aún queda
mucho camino por recorrer agrega que no
sirven de nada estas iniciativas si no
vienen acompañadas de acciones
destinadas a preservar los derechos de
la comunidad y atender sus necesidades
cuando yo empecé hace 25 años atrás esto
no se veía
de todo lo contrario las compañías
corrían de todo lo que tuviera que ver
con la comunidad y aleje de testículos
así que yo creo que hemos avanzado mucho
pero todavía falta mucho para hacer
ciertamente una de las maneras que una
compañía puede demostrar su orgullo y
puede demostrar su solidaridad con la
comunidad al g-20 tedisco plus es
dándole trabajo a las personas trans a
las personas no binarias a las personas
que tradicionalmente no consiguen
trabajo por el discrimen que existe y
tener políticas establecidas que acaben
con ese describen y con ese rechazo que
usualmente se da en estos espacios
laborales yo lamentablemente no he visto
esa inclusión de las personas trans en
estos espacios laborales que tienen que
abogar no tan solo participar de la de
las marchas y las paradas de orgullo de
btt y culpar a mercadear sus productos
sino también yendo a la legislatura y
utilizando su poder para crear políticas
públicas que sean inclusivas y que nos
acerquen hacia la equidad hay compañías
que donan recursos para organizaciones
en apoyo a la causa al eje bético y lo
hacen durante todo el año pero
integrantes de la misma comunidad
denuncia que hay otras que sólo se valen
del mes del orgullo para captar
clientela y generar mayores ingresos una
práctica conocida como weibo capitalismo
o capitalismo arco iris y puede que no
sea casualidad que haya marcas que vean
a las personas de orientación sexual
diversa como clientes ya que una
encuesta de 2019 de la oficina del censo
de eeuu reveló que las parejas casadas
del mismo sexo sobre todo las que están
conformadas por hombres tienen ingresos
más altos que las parejas heterosexuales
también se ha cuestionado el llamado
rainbow washing que podría traducirse
como lavado arcoiris un término que se
utiliza para criticar las estrategias de
marketing que políticos empresas
organizaciones emplean para lavar su
imagen mostrándose como simpatizantes de
la causa del gbc y que cuando en
realidad son ajenos a ésta el portal
independiente popular information reveló
que 25 grandes corporaciones que
modificaron su logo con un arco iris y
patrocinaron desfiles del orgullo gay
durante el mes de junio donaron más de
10 millones de dólares a las campañas de
políticos anti el genético en eeuu en
los últimos dos años reveló también que
estas empresas cuentan con una
calificación del 100 por ciento en el
índice de igualdad corporativa
de la ong human rights campaign aunque
en esta medición no se tienen en cuenta
las donaciones políticas
álex altas director de una compañía
dedicada al posicionamiento de marca
cree que las empresas deben ser más
genuinas a la hora de promover este tipo
de campañas no solamente decir lo que
son sino que hagan lo que dicen ser las
marcas antes hablaba se hablaba de
posicionamiento que es la clara y
diferente opción de completamente al
consumidor y hoy las marcas en tener más
que posicionamiento una posición y una
posición respecto a que pienso y hace y
el rol de la marca dentro de la sociedad
en el mundo se está volviendo más
consciente estamos en la generación de
la versión marketing y regional branding
esta es la generación que estamos
viviendo y la generación del human
branding es
primero soy persona primero soy ser
humano después soy consumidor veamos
ahora como han abordado los medios de
comunicación este tema el diario
británico the guardian titula la
mercancía de arco iris del orgullo está
en todas partes pero quién se queda con
la olla de oro agrega que los productos
temáticos multicolores llegan a las
tiendas a medida que comienzan las
celebraciones de junio pero pocas
ganancias van hacia la comunidad lgtb un
artículo de opinión de mc en bici dice
que si la cantidad de productos con
temática de arcoiris disponibles para
comprar en vitrinas centros comerciales
o en instagram durante junio fuera una
métrica del progreso fácilmente se
podría creer que las personas lgtb take
y han logrado la igualdad total en eeuu
el portal box titula la prime arts o
mercancía del orgullo no salvará a los
jóvenes trans y añade que cuando termina
junio los logotipos arco iris en twitter
y la promoción de mercancía con
purpurina a menudo se abandona las
empresas vuelven a la normalidad y
mientras tanto las personas queers y
trans continúan luchando por sus
derechos básicos
y para finalizar el humor también ha
tenido cabida en esta discusión internet
se ha llenado de memes como estos a
través de los cuales los usuarios en
forma de parodia critican que
regularmente las personas de orientación
sexual diversa no usan productos ni
prendas excesivamente coloridos como los
que las marcas tratan de venderles una
forma satírica de hacerles saber el
desconocimiento que existe respecto a la
realidad de la comunidad lgbt
de esta manera despedimos revista
digital recuerde que si quiere repetir
este u otro capítulo de nuestro programa
lo puede hacer a través de nuestra
página web www puntos france24 puntocom
[Música]